hay una puerta entreabierta para el cese
del conflicto en Ucrania el portavoz del
kremlin respondió a Washington señalando
que las condiciones impuestas por el
presidente Joe biden y el no
reconocimiento de occidente de los
territorios ucranianos anexados por
Rusia hacen imposible la posibilidad de
que Moscú se siente en la mesa de
negociación
Estados Unidos todavía no reconoce los
nuevos territorios de Rusia y por
supuesto esto complica mucho la búsqueda
de una base mutua para las
conversaciones para lograr nuestros
objetivos Putin estuvo y sigue abierto a
las conversaciones con todas las partes
el jueves el mandatario estadounidense
dijo estar dispuesto a negociar con su
homólogo Vladimir Putin siempre y cuando
las tropas rusas abandonen el territorio
ucraniano
Estoy preparado para hablar con el Señor
putins y de hecho está interesado en
buscar una manera de terminar la guerra
él no ha hecho eso todavía si es el caso
en consulta con mis amigos franceses y
de la otan estaré feliz de sentarme con
Putin para ver qué tiene en mente
un clima que según los expertos hace
pensar que no se vislumbran pronto final
a la guerra en Ucrania Esto es lo que
dijo guido larson analista político a
France 24 que pensar en una salida
negociada a estas alturas cuando viene
el invierno europeo es muy poco probable
mi estimación es que debiéramos observar
un desarrollo todavía permanente de la
guerra probablemente por la totalidad
del año 2023 este viernes las
autoridades ucranianas reconocieron que
entre Diez mil y 13.000 de sus soldados
han muerto en la guerra desde la
invasión el pasado 24 de febrero unas
pérdidas que se unen a los territorios
ucranianos anexados por Rusia y que kiev
querría recuperar antes